all right let's talk about prop eight we
can't do one week without something gay
at this when i think is actually kinda
interesting assert Charles Cooper who is
one of the lawyers
that with poor prop a meaning he was
against
marriage equality and bought it at the
Supreme Court
we're not gonna believe this he has put
prop and that the Act he's now
for gay marriage why for his
stepdaughter plays me and want to get
married incredible how this works out
we got a quote from general Cooper my
views about
on issues at this kind the same way as
other people do
and how I view this down the road may
not be the way I view it now or how I
did you did 10 years ago that attorney
Charles Cooper
got to basically that seems good to me
he's trying to get on the right side
history except the
Supreme Court case wasn't that long ago
and is it a little disingenuous like now
it affected you
personally so you're gonna get on the
right I like this kinda
in a weird way I'm happy that happened
but it kinda seems like it
dick move activity we cancel judge him
right there until you get her a judge in
with the app
know when you're here this are you okay
I'm fine with that i mean good for him
but like that very question mark yeah
like good for you that you personally
affected you and now you're deciding
that you have to not be an asshole
yet can you guys the Busby do some sorta
wanted those
what do you call on that frickin tests
the you know with the quizzes can you do
want the quizzes
I like how you evolved on gay marriage
with all your crazy can you make it go
do that right now he's after that you
make that
really I mean I took its good he did a
but like it's literally about what is it
about a year later something media
throughout with less than a year later
at like nine months later and it seems
like will it affect you personally seen
a
gonna come on board like it I
she blows my mind that there are still
people in this country who
don't see that this war has been lost
guy them
like bigots have lost this war it's just
going to happen
it's not there's no going back now and
to its it's the equivalent love being
a segregationist in 1982
layer its you it the wars done right and
so
the fact with more shocking is that
there are there are so many people who
haven't evolved their stance I'm did
there should be graciously accept this
guy should be like yeah sure you for it
you forget that less than a year ago in
the supreme court but about you have a
lesbian step daughter
welcome I mean I think good thoughts I
think it well I we are accepting but I
also think it's a great
feather in the cap because that if even
this guy I mean this is this is Darth
Vader like hanging out he walks like
it's
I its impossible to be touched by this
issue personally
and not come to the right conclusion
if Dick Cheney who I'm pretty sure is an
evil robot sent from the future
can be for gay marriage because his
daughter is
then really it's the least you can ask
if somebody
it actually the least you can add so is
this just proves that the number one
thing the gay people can do is come out
because look it happen with Dick Cheney
when his daughter came out he came
around this guy's daughter came out we
had that there was a problem order I
think
senator his and Sun came out sir so it's
basically like if you come out you can
pretty much affect the the convictions a
collocation but I am
they are a positive way of thinking
about a a ended up being like actually
be gracious which now we will
yes we should be gracious what should we
just accept that should the gay
community just accept all these people
no matter what they've done in their
passion in the second you change
should you be as exonerated about what a
bitch really marching in the Pride
Parade
but we can like we can who hate him what
we can is except that he evolved on the
issue
without making him like a you know a gay
icon yeah and if you want to be gay icon
but I think maybe not make him would
have to morph into an old lady probably
fishing where our way we act yeah but I
think now
now arm do you think it matters even if
he's not doing is necessary because his
daughter but just for
selling a book cuz I think that's also
part a bit like how do you sell your
book lie with the property lawyer report
against
gay marriage and now i'm for it but saw
a book you know I care
some element but should be even take
that be right back I
ice think whatever gets people on the
right side of this issue is a good thing
I don't think that makes them
great people cuz I don't think this
issue makes being
for gay marriage in saying that people
who love each other should be able to
get married
doesn't make you a good person that's
just what as
people we should expect to be covered
you know an extra credit
that yet well I mean I would love some
extra credit has given extra credit is
what time are you
yeah totally for being a yeah an ally
for being an ally
you know i i do what I can the I
up does anyone about the other way %uh
that it doesn't make anything is there
anyone
thats pro-gay marriage that certainly
have we heard that at all
because maybe that's true but I went to
Berkeley which is a very liberal school
the largest urban campus actually they
called republicans because
people come world moderate and they're
so freaked out by liberalism that they
like backtrack and
I'm these really conservative like
asshole so I feel like
that could happen like to get so scared
about like it
marriage equality I mean I just a minute
like double down to become like super
anti after thinking it was okay
yeah is not a little bit like the
chick-fil-a theory like the more you
for the more the gates bought cheaply
the more chicken they sold like a little
better that
or the more that they for duck dynasty
said only the ratings were cute now I
guess there
all Great Hall Paula Dean still people
rally behind polity every time she's a
subject of our race is that what
happened I think they may be eligible to
hear it for her brand
yeah knob no I I think with people will
begin to devolve on this issue
to devolve on this issue when a gay
divorce
still hurts yeah started popping up
you'll see a lot of gay people who'll be
like
you know like I don't know who's right
for me you know gay marriage in phiri is
great but
yeah I want to go back to the sink or I
do you have a friend right now that a
lesbian in the middle in the works and I
feel like it's very that's very edging
what do you think that they live in a
horse first though
you know they're headed toward letter
endorsing a very first do they got very
first a divorce for ca$h
there's some you are jokers but I i've
walked up to the edge into a turnaround
got were
we thank the good allies like to make
that joke I
up